- [Narrator] In the heart of Mexico City
is a school exclusively
for gifted children.
(whooshes)
And at the heart of that school
is a gifted 16-year-old prodigy,
(whooshes)
named Dafne Almazán.
(cheerful music)
(playing piano)
- [Narrator] Dafne is a child prodigy
who became the world's
youngest psychologist
at the age of 13,
and Forbes Magazine named her
one of Mexico's most powerful women.
(paper crinkles)
At 14, she received her
masters in education,
and right now, she is
finishing a doctorate in law.
(whooshes)
As if that wasn't enough,
Dafne speaks English,
French, Latin and Mandarin,
and finds time during the
day to study them all.
Did I say that she's only 16?
- Yes, you did.
- [Narrator] It is estimated that there is
over one million gifted
children in Mexico,
with a talent waiting to be tapped.
So Dafne is committed to nurturing
the vast talent of the
gifted children of Mexico.
That's why she teaches psychology
at the school she once graduated from,
Centro de Atención al Talento.
(upbeat string music)
(playing piano)
(upbeat guitar music)
(exhales)
(thuds)
(punches)
- [Narrator] For example,
there's this science whiz kid
who knows the entire periodic table
like the back of his hand.
- [Narrator] Or this
kid, with a sharp memory
that allows him to memorize
every bone in the human body.
- [Narrator] There is this 6-year-old kid
presenting on an interesting subject.
(majestic orchestral music)
(tonal music)